[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN HAYNE: Spring break
is an amazing opportunity
to be able to go abroad
and have the material
in your course come to life.
JANET MONGE: Kenya and East Africa
is the origin of our lineage,
so these environments are
really key to understand humans
in total.
WENDY HELLER: Venice is both
permanent and fragile,
and we want them to understand
it from all those aspects.
KEVIN HAYNE: I got to know these
professors on a new level,
rather than just on the
classroom experience.
SCHUYLER KEAN: I've gotten different
perspectives on nature,
on humans, on politics,
from being on this trip
with these people, and it's
brought me closer to them.
[CHATTER]
WENDY HELLER: So the
library's where
I did a lot of my
dissertation research.
The entrance is right there.
We chose to focus the
course on Venice,
because it is just such an
exciting and beautiful city
with a very rich history.
And since Professor Reuland
and I have both worked here
for our research, we felt
that we wanted students
to come to know the city
from all of its aspects.
Not just as scholars,
but as human beings.
And to embrace the culture in
the way that we've embrace it.
SOPHIA FEIST: Studying
abroad, especially
as part of a Princeton class,
just expands your worldview
in a really profound way that
is really impossible when you're
looking at images in
books and learning very
theoretically about a subject.
When you actually get
to communicate with it
and see it in person,
you remember a lot
of what you learned in
the class better and are
able to put it into
context, and not
just through the guidance
of a teacher or a book.
JAMIE REULAND:
Venice's history is
a very modern history in a way.
It's a very
contemporary history.
It brings up really
contemporary issues.
We're facing environmental
catastrophe on an unseen scale
today, and so thinking about
just a single city that
creates beauty on
ground that's not solid
when there's a real realization
that the foundations are not
stable I think is a really,
really interesting and really
contemporary and relevant issue.
KEVIN HAYNE: When I saw this
course on Venice that actually
has the opportunity to go there,
I immediately jumped on it.
I really felt that I got to know
Professor Reuland and Professor
Heller on a new level,
rather than just
on the classroom experience,
which was something very, very
unique.
WENDY HELLER: We brought them
to Venice during spring break
so that halfway
through the semester,
they could see that this is a
real place, that it was three
dimensions, that the frescoes
that we saw on PowerPoint
are on walls of churches.
So that we could go
into the Accademia
and see the Carpaccio's
"Saint Ursula"
cycle being restored,
and hear a lecture
from the experts who know
about the restoration.
This is something they
can't do on video,
they can't do on YouTube.
What's so special is to
get Princeton students
and let them see the
city through our eyes,
and then they will show it to
their students, their children,
their partners, and it will
always be a part of them.
So that's part of
the joy of teaching
at a place like
Princeton, is being
able to share that
with our students.
JANET MONGE: The human
evolution class is a class
that's designed to really give
a full frame, essentially,
of human evolution from
their first appearance --
probably about 6 or
7 million years ago --
up to the present.
The students who came to
Princeton Mpala program
for spring break are a
subset of our students
that are really interested
in delving deeper
into that pre-history.
We've been able to sample
many different aspects
of human evolution while we've
been here, and up to, really,
some of the challenges
of modern times as well.
VIVIAN UFONGENE: I
personally have never
traveled outside of the
United States before.
I think being able to
travel abroad and actually
be able to see the things
that we're learning about
is unimaginable.
I had no idea what an
excavation site looked like
or what a 2 million-year-old
fossil looked like.
It was just something
you have in your head.
You can never really see it.
And I think that is exponential
in terms of learning ability.
SCHUYLER KEAN: I chose to take
this class because, again, I'm
an anthropology
major, and I'm doing
a certificate in archaeology.
So of course human
evolution is something
that would really broaden
my understanding of not only
human evolution, but what it
means, in a sense, to be human.
That's a really important
part of anthropology.
DINO J. MARTINS:
Coming to Mpala allows
the anthropology
students to think
about our role in the
world and in the universe
and in the ecology
of the savanna,
given that we're one
of the species that
has come out of the
African savanna
and gone on to be so successful.
It's wonderful for me
to see, as a scientist,
that the students became
engaged and inspired,
that that sense of wonder
was really sparked,
and that it allowed them to put
the lessons from the classroom
into a broader context
in terms of a life lesson
and an experience
that will go forward
in shaping their future.
PABLO BICKENBACH:
Things are very
different when you're actually
in the field living it.
One thing is when you
read it from a textbook
or when a professor delivers
a lecture using slides,
but a very different thing
is being in the place
and getting the feel
of it, experiencing it,
and really seeing how
things are in real life.
That's just the best
way of learning.
[SINGING]
JANET MONGE: It's really
key for the students
to ground a lot of their
thoughts and studies
in this part of the world.
It's been an earth-changing
experience for them,
because of course, you
get to actually walk
where our ancestors walked,
think about the things
and look at the environments
that our ancestors did.
Never having been in this
situation or anything
like this kind of
situation, it really
is a mind-altering
experience for them,
and an experiment for
them to really conceive
of this in those terms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]